louis xiv
or in french louis quatorze the Sun
Kings radians shown far beyond the realm
of France as did his infamy
weeks weeks extravagant luxury near
decadence
yes Versailles the Sun came the grandeur
of France promoting the arts all this
way too expensive stuff way too
expensive
Lord sparks his most famous gardens are
in Versailles southwest of Paris Louis
had the palace built in the mid 17th
century to be his residence and seat of
government a new exhibition at the
palace examines the Sun Kings death
three hundred years ago the court
mourned for a set number of days even
the Kings passing followed a rigid
protocol he died as he lived on public
display he was bedridden on his final
days but he still governed from his room
in the heart of the palace he held his
usual morning and evening receptions and
the luncheons were still public he
consulted his ministers continued to
govern the kingdom and in addition he
arranged for his succession ministry low
volume is your to organizes a Sukkah
system louis xiv was just four years old
when he ascended the throne in 1643 his
mother appointed a chief minister to
govern when the minister died Louie
assumed power at age 22 he made himself
the absolute monarch a regent of
superlatives
we could do badly he not only exerted
influence he governed he was the one who
had to say he gave the orders he was the
king who ruled it had nothing to do with
today's constitutional monarchy it was
actually Louis who gave all the
instructions the embodiment of this
absolute power is the Palace of
Versailles the zenith of european
palatial architecture louis xiv laid the
cornerstone for Paris's famed Schanz
Alizee another creation of louis
architects the domed is on the lead
louis xiv became synonymous with the
style of an era over to lament compose
art you keep finding the same stylistic
elements whether on a little case or an
enormous building both its design
vocabulary is a code for the spirit of
those times the taste for colors and
contrast for example and of course a
taste for luxury and gold lips a low and
for fashion Under the Sun King Paris
became Europe's capital of style and the
birthplace of oak kochira in its present
form the city still inspires
international designers among them the
French fashion house Chanel Louis the
14th was a patron of numerous artists
musicians poets and authors he himself
took center stage as the figure of the
Sun King and took on mythical dimensions
that inspire creative spirits everywhere
the Hollywood motion picture the man in
the iron mask for instance portrays the
Regent as an unscrupulous tyrant amid a
life of pomp and splendor continue
another Hollywood production inspired by
Lois is due out soon even 300 years
after his demise
the fascination with the sovereign lives
on the new exhibition will no doubt lure
thousands of visitors into Versailles
baroque chambers louis xiv continues to
command attention
he was the greatest king in the world
that's why he's being celebrated here
even though he was once hated by the
French because he was a very warlike
King it was our greatest hour P embodied
France's most glorious era we katella's
was himself entirely consumed with his
function as king he embodied everything
that was the state who's guilty at the
end of his life he said my depart but
the state shall always remain the mayor
during his reign he was feared by all
today his cultural legacy retains its
fascination even beyond Frances borders